so it's a non-financial application this
question of series and sequences it's
usually serious by the way it's not my
kind of thing look carefully at the
question because it's not the language
you're used to if someone will repays
this and so on borrows it it can often
cause a bit of a destroyer I don't know
where to start with this however if I
tell you in advance okay this kind of
question essentially is no different at
all to what you've been dealing with
already okay um hopefully that helps you
we're going to take the same rich we're
going to build it from scratch good
series
try and get like a general term and then
we'll see we can do a general sorry
general sum then see what we can do to
act answer the question then pose in to
us okay
so I list that with the set up a
hospital patient receives a 10 milligram
dose of medicine at intervals of 4 hours
now you tell me what do you think is the
most important piece of information in
that sentence anything else it's
important 10 milligram okay now by the
way just for this particular example I'm
going to suggest that this are four
hours here is actually a red herring
they're just putting more information to
see if you're paying attention but you
tell me why that's a needless missing
piece of information by the time we get
to end the question okay during each
interval the amount of medicine in the
body reduces to 75 percent of the amount
of prison to stop 75 percent okay so
again crucial piece of information
suppose you could write it as 75 percent
right what's this gonna mean as a series
question every interval you're gonna be
multiplying by 75 percent or
three-quarters okay so three quarters as
a number what is it significance to our
question it's going to be probably the
common ratio and that we're going to add
appear right
that doesn't make this team yeah as we
build a serious economy okay all right
and he's getting this is how much is
being lost but then at the end of that
period that interval he gets a new now
the question is really there always be
less than less than less than 40
sorry less than 40 milligrams of
medicine in the body irrespective of how
long the treatment goes for okay so can
someone tell me why we didn't need this
piece of information
yeah it doesn't matter how light could
be for hours or four minutes or four
seconds because according to this
question they're not actually asking for
a period of time like how long will it
take to get to this and they just say
for any period of time it should always
meet this condition that's what we're
required to prove okay so let's begin
and we need to set up some terms and
language and technology for ourselves so
I'm gonna call this I'm sorry let I'm
gonna call it am for medicine okay let
em a and B now I can define this in a
variety of ways and the way that I
define it will sometimes make the
question easier for me to solve
sometimes make it harder okay I'm going
to suggest let's make it the amount of
medicine left the amount of medicine or
in the body
the amount of medicine in the body
remaining after now by the way if you
got another color that will be helpful
because you want to highlight things
like after that's a crucial equation
formula difference making word right
after the interval okay so having said
that up for myself and it's always
that's that's a hard part because you
don't get told this is what you need to
set up I just have to build my series
right so m1 at the end of the first
interval so I guess after four hours
have passed what things have happened
what things well we've given the patient
their first line of medicine right so
there was that ten milligrams that was
started me okay at the beginning we gave
the medicine and then time is elapsed
right so I'm looking at the after
or at the end of the unthinkable so how
much medicine is left out
so many ups in that right so 3/4 done
that's how it's a 7.5 ok
I couldn't simplify it but don't really
help me that much because I'm gonna need
this Terminator on the next interval
what has happened two things have
happened the same two things that
happened in the first interval namely we
gave more medicine and and some of it
you know in February always used up or
whatever okay so which happened first
did we give medicine first
or did it fade away and first we gave
the first right at the start of each
interval we give the medicine so there
was what was left before and the next
instant we give more medicine there's
the new ten milligrams okay and then
four hours pass okay that's really
crucial that you get what's happening
very carefully and you talk it out to
yourself so you know you know for
instance you do x two recorders first
and then advert it because I'll give you
a totally different series now I'll
expand this usually expanding to bad
idea usually factorizing is nice up okay
but expanding here shows us that the
series is starting okay I also want to
draw your attention to the fact that
even though this question has nothing to
do with money you see the similarities
right so key are we that that ten is of
giving me medicine right which really is
analogous to by making a repayment
something like that
okay this is three quarters here three
quarters that's the the medicine sort of
dissipated what might that be similar to
in a financial situation it wouldn't
make sense to fur to the interest its
unto me why done white pages
you invest money what does interest
video money it makes it bigger right so
if it was interested should be you know
one plus something like 1.25 or whatever
okay what this is doing is making it
smaller so what does it behave like
terms of financing I guess the closest
can be depreciation okay cuz like I
bought my car
I literally have all my car and the
second I bought it it's it's getting
less and less valuable okay so that's
act three-quarters thing happy just
getting some more
okay sure is that enough to get a
pattern maybe I want to do one more just
to be safe every what happens I've got
the amount after the end of the second
into it and then I add my new ten right
after adding my medicine for hours
passes and by that time we've lost a
quarter of what was left ok so again I'm
going to spare
now I'm gonna stop there and I'm going
to let you have a finger down without me
holding your hand now how am I going to
use this to prove what was asked which
was an irrespective of how by don't you
know m4 m5 m6 m600 okay there say this
amount whatever it is will never exceed
40 milligrams how did you do that